"I don't recognize the people. I can't form any associations.
Kermit means nothing to me."
You don't get anywhere, thinking of them as dreams.
Well, I've more or less said what I wanted.
I think I just want to recapitulate and say this is common.
Think of the number of blind people.
There must be hundreds of thousands of blind people
who have these hallucinations
but are too scared to mention them.
So this sort of thing needs to be brought into notice,
for patients, for doctors, for the public.
Finally, I think they are infinitely interesting and valuable,
for giving one some insight as to how the brain works.
Charles Bonnet said, 250 years ago --
he wondered how, thinking of these hallucinations,
how, as he put it, the theater of the mind
could be generated by the machinery of the brain.
Now, 250 years later,
I think we're beginning to glimpse how this is done.
Thanks very much.
(Applause)
Chris Anderson: That was superb. Thank you so much.
You speak about these things with so much insight
and empathy for your patients.
Have you yourself experienced any of the syndromes you write about?
Oliver Sacks: I was afraid you would ask that.
(Laughter)
Well, yeah, a lot of them.
And, actually, I'm a little visually impaired myself.
I'm blind in one eye and not terribly good in the other.
And I see the geometrical hallucinations.
But they stop there.
CA: And they don't disturb you?
Because you understand what's doing it, it doesn't make you worried?
OS: Well, they don't disturb me any more than my tinnitus,
which I ignore.
They occasionally interest me,
and I have many pictures of them in my notebooks.
I've gone and had an fMRI myself,
to see how my visual cortex is ticking over.
And when I see all these hexagons
and complex things, which I also have,
in visual migraine,
I wonder whether everyone sees things like this
and whether things like cave art or ornamental art
may have been derived from them a bit.
CA: That was an utterly, utterly fascinating talk.
Thank you so much for sharing.
OS: Thank you. Thank you.
(Applause)